today we're wrapping up next and talking
about confidential computing and machine
learning
i'm jenny and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news if you've been
hanging out with us for the past nine
weeks
we've worked on an actual ton of content
with next on
air it's been a lot of fun but it can
also be hard to keep track of all the
different topics we've covered
that's why we've compiled a full list of
announcements so you can review and get
more on all your favorites
no matter how you want to use google
cloud your data is your
data we're always looking to improve
security and now we've announced
confidential computing
this keeps your data even more secure by
keeping data encrypted in memory
and away from the cpu we've recently
launched confidential vms and are now
expanding that security to confidential
gke nodes
building ml and ai apps can take a lot
of work
but there's more tooling than ever to
help you capture the power of
ml dale markowitz applied ai engineer
has put together a list of helpful tools
and tips to how to spend more time on
your application
and less time on tweaking your models we
love good documentation as it can help
make a hard project possible
code samples are always welcome and now
it's even easier to use them
thanks to interactive documentation you
can put in your specific values
and the code samples will update to
match exactly what you need
and you can even preview actual results
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link in the description
any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us and we'll
see you in the cloud